[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had derived the
equation of the elastica
as well as the boundary conditions which
i have written down here and today we
are going to see
an application of this theory towards
the same example problem
that we had considered earlier using the
approximate theory
so this is that example uh is exactly
the same diagram except that i have
changed
the coordinate system earlier the x was
directed
uh along the same direction along which
i have written this s here
and the z was perpendicular to it okay
now if you just compare with the
previous page at which i had ended the
previous video
uh you will see that there's a slight
difference in the way that the boundary
conditions are written here
you see i have written here this is at x
equal to zero
and at x equal to l these things um
either e i d theta d s equal to zero or
theta
specified but in reality this should
have been written
as s equal to zero and s equal to l
so uh so this is
s and this is s okay
so that's a bit of a correction but it
is not really a correction in the sense
that in the undeformed configuration of
the beam
that is in the pre-buckling stage
it is indeed true that x
what i had previously written and the
s which i am now writing uh they
are coincident which you can clearly see
in the diagram here
okay so in this undeformed configuration
that is in the pre-buckling stage
there is no difference between the s
that i have written here
uh so and the x that was
uh that was otherwise present okay so
with this much of a little discussion
let us launch into the solution
of this governing equation and let us
see what uh what answer it gives us
when we use these boundary conditions
but please note that
although these equations look uh simpler
compared to
the the previously obtained
approximate theory there will be some
challenges
okay and the first challenge that we
have to deal with is that
this governing differential equation
that you see here it is
uh a uh so this derivative term
uh is certainly a linear term but
we do have the presence of a
non-linearity through the presence of
this sine theta term
and that is going to uh throw up in
a good challenge in front of us but
we'll deal with it
and we'll deal with it immediately so we
start out with this equation
e i d square theta
the s square plus p sine theta
equal to zero and the way we deal with
this non-linearity
is with a standard trick uh which is
used in all
of uh mathematical modeling in various
various areas of mathematical modeling
uh in quite quite various
varied areas actually but we can have a
discussion about that later
so uh what we do here is to multiply
throughout
by d theta d s okay so it seems for no
rhyme or reason that we're doing it but
you will see the beauty
of this trick in just a while okay so we
just multiply throughout
by d theta d s so this is the this is
the
real trick here to deal with this
non-linearity sorry about that
i missed writing this d theta d s okay
now you see uh
what we can do is to rewrite this term
in this fashion
you just take a moment to appreciate the
beauty of what we just did
okay so what was present as
a as a second order term we have now
represented it as uh in this form dds
of d theta d s whole square so this is
the
derivative over this entire thing okay
uh and if you if you just if you just
simplify this you will get back this
thing
okay so what is the motivation behind
this you'll see that in a moment
okay now uh what we are going to do
is to write this term also
as a derivative with respect to s
this is d d s of minus cos theta
and i believe some of you have already
figured out what is the motivation here
you see in both these terms we have
managed to write
it as we have to have managed to write
them as dds of something dds of
something
okay so this is basically just asking
for it for us to integrate it
with respect to s okay so if we do that
we integrate once with respect to s
then we obtained
this here and
this here but we also
end up with a constant of integration
a constant which we don't of course know
so our first job is to actually
uh figure out something regarding this
constant okay so let us take stock of
what we know and what we don't know
uh so maybe it is a good time to take a
look at the boundary conditions that we
have so first of all you note
that uh this end is pinned
and this end is also pinned which means
that we cannot say anything a priory
regarding the slopes
of this beam or this column at this end
or either
or this end we do not know anything a
priority
about the slope so uh
all that we can say is that theta here
at s equal to 0 and theta here at s
equal to l they are not specified
okay so we must conclude that
at s equal to 0 and s
equal to l theta is not specified
which means we have to conclude that it
must be true
that at s equal to zero and at s equal
to l
e i d theta d s is equal to zero
all right
since the ends at s equal to 0
and s equal to l
are pinned
theta is not specified
therefore
at s equal to zero and
s equal to l we must have that e
i d theta d s is equal to zero now this
should immediately make us
uh quite happy because uh we do have the
presence of this
uh d theta d s and uh
because you see our ultimate or our goal
here our immediate
goal here is to find this c but
uh even though we obtain this value of t
d theta d s but we still don't know
about this
theta itself okay and that is actually
problematic because we have just now
said that theta
is not specified so we don't know this
theta and unless we know this theta
we do not know this cos theta also
now what can we do about it
okay so right now as things stand we
simply don't know how to deal with this
unknown theta the only thing that we can
say however
is that because this entire situation is
uh symmetric up
at s equal to zero and is equal to l so
if
uh if it buckles it'll buckle like that
so uh the only thing that we can say
regarding this theta uh is that uh it is
going to have the same value at s equal
to zero and at s equal to
l okay but we don't know those values
okay so uh
what we are going to do is uh
we are going to just say that let it be
some value
alpha let that theta be equal to alpha
at s equal to 0
and s equal to l
sorry about that uh
okay
all right
so uh so the only thing that we can say
is that uh
that at s equal to zero
at s equal to zero
let theta is equal to alpha
please note that this alpha
is not known
therefore what we can say at s equal to
l
is that theta should be equal to minus
alpha
the reason we say that is if you
consider
this beam or rod and then you consider
the deformation like this
then at s equal to 0
if you have this angle alpha this angle
this is minus alpha okay the magnitude
remains
alpha but in terms of the algebraic sign
because you know that theta is one of
our coordinate one of our coordinate
variables
okay so we have to be careful about the
sign so if you are
calculating or if you are denoting the
positivity of theta in this direction
from uh from this from this horizontal
line
in the anti-clockwise sense so
so this angle uh that uh
that should be minus alpha okay now
uh now how do we how do we use all of
these things
okay so what we are going to do is to
go back to the
to the form that we have obtained here
and then write this thing at s equal to
0
and at s equal to l
so at s equal to 0 we have
e i d theta
d s squared
minus p cos
alpha please note that this term
is 0 at s equal to 0 so this is c so c
is equal to minus p cos alpha
similarly you do it at s equal to l
this is again
like this but p cos minus alpha is
simply p cos
alpha because the positivity or
negativity inside the cost doesn't
matter
so from both of these what we are
obtaining
uh thankfully we are the same thing uh
we are obtaining that c is equal to
minus p cos alpha therefore
what we conclude is that in general
in general all throughout the domain
as we had obtained earlier
it is going to be e i d theta d s cos a
whole square
minus p cos theta that is going to be
equal to
minus e cos alpha
now let's see how we can simplify this
let us not lose sight of the fact of
what we are trying to achieve here
okay so our our ultimate goal
uh is twofold
first of all we do want to find out
uh exactly like our previous approximate
theory
uh as to what the critical value
of the load the p is such that buckling
will be induced that is certainly our
first goal
but uh previously we had seen that in
our approximate theory
even though we we managed to find out
the critical value of this p
which would induce the buckling but we
could not say anything regarding the
deflection itself we could say that it
was buckling
but as to as regards to its amplitude or
how much the deflection was taking place
that remained
an unknown and we had said that that is
a shortcoming of that
theory because we are now dealing with a
more exact theory
it is naturally our hope that it is
going to uh
give us something better okay so let us
let us try to see if we can indeed
proceed
towards something which would give us
some estimate
of the deflection all right but uh but
we have to traverse quite a bit uh
before we can reach that stage
all right
now you see uh
after this after the stage has been
reached uh
what we would like to do
is we have to take the square root of
this thing
okay so let us do that
[Music]
uh i think i missed a half all
throughout
yeah so all throughout this i missed a
half
it did not matter here although it
should be present
but here it does matter otherwise i'll
get my coefficients wrong
okay so now uh
this is twice p by e i
cos theta uh this should be
cos alpha
all right
square root of that now the question is
are because we are taking the square
root
whether it should be positive or it
should be negative
that is the question in front of us so
so in an actual classroom environment i
actually spent some time asking the
students this
so i prefer if you just pause the video
for a bit
uh uh because uh i'm just going to
reveal the answer
uh immediately here okay so the answer
is that
this square root should come with a
negative sign and not the positive sign
because you see this theta
is actually starting out from this
positive value of alpha
it is the slope is uh going
up like that okay so the the curve is
going like that
so the slope is actually decreasing and
you can see that
uh at this midpoint the slope has
actually become zero
and thereby it is becoming more and more
negative until
it reaches this value of minus alpha so
d theta d s as we are traversing along
s is actually uh decreasing
from alpha through 0 to minus alpha
okay so it is negative so the reason
that we point out here
is that it is a negative sign
because theta is decreasing from alpha
to minus alpha through 0.
all right that is a crucial step now uh
we'll do a bit of algebraic manipulation
here so let me just
copy this this step here and proceed in
the next
page
sorry about that
i hope it works this time all right
so this is simplified as the right hand
side is simplified as
uh we use a bit of trigonometric
identity
write this as uh this cos theta as 1
minus 2 sine square theta by 2
and this cos alpha is 1 minus 2 sine
square
alpha by 2 so that overall what we are
going to end up
with is this thing
twice sine squared alpha by 2
minus twice
cos square theta by 2
that is also under the square root which
basically means that this is
is the four p by e i uh
but what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to consider or set it up in a
fashion which will
enable me to carry out an integration
okay so i'll write the ds
and then
i am skipping a couple of steps here
um this this actually will come in the
in the denominator but uh you please
note
that what i'm basically doing is kind of
like d s is going that side and this
entire thing is going to the denominator
here
and uh the d theta is present
here and this is left as
sine square alpha by 2 minus
this should be sine
and this thing is under the square root
let us not forget that
okay and
we intend to carry out the integration
here
so this
ds integration with respect to s uh
is going from 0 to l now this thing this
integration
you note that now this theta is actually
going
from alpha to minus alpha as
s is going from 0 to l that is very
important to note
okay so uh just because we are writing
it like an integration please do not be
tempted to write
is it as minus alpha to alpha okay
so you have to write it corresponding to
the limits of
s that we have put here so when s is
equal to 0
on the right hand side you have theta
equal to its
its value at s equal to 0 which is alpha
and when s equal to l the theta is equal
to minus
alpha okay so
we can do a little bit of the
simplification here again
exploiting the symmetry of this
of this theta uh so what we are going to
do is
we know that this entire integration is
going to be symmetric
about uh about theta equal to 0
which corresponds to this uh
to the midpoint so
we leave this as it is but on the right
hand side
it's just a bit of a simplification uh
we write this as integration
uh alpha to zero
[Music]
d theta
please note that
we can do this so i must not forget to
write this 2 here
i can do this because this here is a
sine squared
theta by 2. so this is an even function
okay that's why i'm allowed to do this
so now
taking this entire integration from
alpha to minus alpha s twice of alpha to
zero
okay because whatever happens from alpha
to zero is the exact same thing that
happens
from zero to minus alpha
okay now uh
what this will give me so this
integration is simply l
and on the right hand side you note that
this 2 cancels with the square root of
4.
ok so what we end up with is this thing
i'll leave this thing as it is
okay again i i wish to emphasize
that our ultimate objective here or at
least our first objective here
is to find out the critical value of p
uh
which will induce buckling okay so all
our efforts our
all all these efforts are directed
towards that goal
now there are some standard procedures
to proceed from here
uh i say standard because the result
that we'll end up with
uh that has a certain very special form
uh in fact such a special form that
it will look quite uh and i'll
illustrate this to you but i'm just
giving i'm
just telling you uh as a precursor
that uh that final form has
it it's it will be complicated looking
but it has such a special form
and such general utility in many areas
of mathematical modeling and applied
mathematics
uh is that um in packages like symbolic
python
it is actually uh built in so we can
actually call those kinds of forms
so we'll see what i'm talking about so
now what we do
right now is we make the substitution
okay we make the substitution
sine theta by 2
as a sine
phi okay now and this might seem like
completely alien to you
uh but uh you'll soon see
i mean the motivation behind this
we make this substitution sine theta by
2 is equal to k sine phi
where k is equal to sine alpha by 2.
okay like
uh one may ask like i mean why in the
world would we
do such a thing so just i mean one
motivation you can pick out here is that
uh if you write it like this uh and we
substitute it
uh here then this uh
this term is going to give us uh sine
square alpha by 2 which is quite
common with this then multiplied by sine
squared phi
so now it helps us to take out this
sine square alpha by 2 as common so that
is one motivation
so so let me write this down
therefore l is equal to minus
e i by p
um
see i have to be a little bit careful
here because
when i make this substitution uh
this you see this limit here
or or this integration here is with
respect to theta but when i make this
substitution
i am going over from theta to phi
so uh it will be perhaps better
if i instead of writing down the next
step
of with regards to the making the
substitution
if i just write down what happens to
this
to this
the distance to the d theta term okay so
from sine theta by 2
is equal to k sine phi
if i carry out one
differentiation with respect to theta
what i'm going to get
is this thing
all right and on the right hand side i'm
going to get
so i am actually
carrying out the differentiation of this
entire
thing with respect to phi so
it is as if we are getting a d theta d
phi here and on the right hand side will
be just
cos phi and then i am taking this d phi
to this
to this side okay so again skipping a
step here but
i'm sure you you understand what what
just went on here
okay now that we have this now you see
that uh
i i wish to make a substitution for this
d theta also
so what is going to happen is that
this d theta is going to be expressed
so this 2 goes here and this cos theta
comes here
cos theta by 2 comes here
so if i make all of these substitutions
therefore making the substitutions
actually making the substitutions what
we end up with
is square root of e i by p
from here
i'm not going to write down the limits
just yet
uh for the d theta i'm writing this
as twice k cos phi
divided by cos theta by 2
and then in the denominator what i have
is sine square alpha by 2
minus sine square
alpha by 2 please note that this sine
square alpha by 2
is basically coming from the
substitution of this sine square theta
so this this k square sine square phi
that k square i'm replacing by this
thing sine square alpha by 2
and i i end up with this sine square
phi okay
and that thing is like this
okay now uh please note
that it is important to to figure out
the the limits of phi uh
corresponding to the limits of ah theta
okay so when theta uh
if you if you look at here so when uh
theta is
equal to alpha
this is sine alpha by 2 and k is also
so we can just figure it out here in our
rough column that
theta is equal to alpha by sorry
alpha or theta equal to alpha
i will have sine alpha by 2 so i'm
basically using this
expre this equation here
a sine phi but k itself is this
sine alpha by 2 which means that sine
phi is equal to 1 which means
that phi is equal to pi by 2
okay so please don't be worried with the
fact
about the the cyclic
values of this pi now we just want to
have the base value here
next for theta is equal to 0 because
you note that in the previous page
the limits that we're dealing with is
theta going from alpha to 0
so we have theta is equal to 0 here for
the upper limit
and for that what we are going to get is
this this sine
0 by 2 basically so that's 0 and then we
have this k
sine phi which basically means
that phi is also equal to 0 so the
limits
uh for this integration with respect to
the phi
because you know that i forgotten to
write this d phi
here the since the entire integration is
now with respect to phi
the limits also should be appropriate
appropriately written
for the phi so they should be or
going from this phi equal to pi by 2 to
pi equal to 0 corresponding to theta
equal to alpha
going to theta equal to 0 which was what
we had earlier
now a little bit of the simplification
is definitely possible
here but only a little bit
we have this cos phi here
we have this cos theta by 2 also here
now you see
this sine square alpha by 2
so that that can come out up
as
sine alpha by 2 and you see
it's not such a bad situation here
because k is equal to sine alpha by 2
and we have a k in the
numerator already present
and what is left here is this
[Music]
sine squared phi
okay so
what we have here is
this thing
and we have this d5 here
zero so i am going to immediately cancel
this
k with this sine alpha by two
what will what we are left with is
twice cos phi now this is 1 minus sine
square phi
so that is cos square phi but there is a
square root here
so we end up with this cos phi also
so that will cancel with the numerator
but please don't forget that i have a
cos theta
by 2 here and that cos theta by 2
now has to be written in terms of
the a sine phi okay
that will do in the next step
so therefore l
is equal to minus ei
sorry about that
this is one minus
sine squared theta by two
okay and that
you see that sine theta by 2 we already
have
made a substitution here sine theta by 2
is equal to k
sine phi so
this we can write ultimately
as 1 minus
a square sine square
y
with the square root all right
now uh
let me just check if i've made any
mistakes here
uh in going from
[Music]
a step to this step let me just check
from the beginning
all right so
in going from this step to this step i
have missed this 2 here
ok this 2 here so that should be very
much
present let me just bring it bring it to
this side
um
okay so this particular form
okay this was what i was talking about
earlier
uh you see this my okay i'll make
another one last simplification
you see this is a minus here and this
integration has this weird
looking limits so let us let us make it
a little bit uh
aesthetically more pleasing by writing
it like this
we just reverse the limits
by absorbing this minus sign
okay so this particular form of the
integration that we have ended up with
that is very weird looking
okay but the good news is that this
weird looking form
it arises in a number of different
fields this was what i
what i was uh telling you earlier okay
so
uh it is it is so very common and so
very important
in applied mathematics and mathematical
modeling that
it has actually been presented in a
built-in form
in packages like symbolic python and
mathematica okay so what this is
referred to
as the complete elliptic integral of the
first kind
in fact these things are so very
important that you will find
entire wikipedia pages uh devoted
to just this integration believe it or
not so i encourage you to
just just do a google search on this
uh on this term okay
it is referred to as the complete
elliptic integral of the first kind
now uh all that is fine but as far as
our goal of obtaining
the critical value of p
where do we stand okay
so
what we say here is that given a
particular value of
p okay given a particular value of
p what can we do about this
uh this integral okay suppose we do know
how to
find out these values the value of this
integral
using symbolic python or some numerical
techniques or whatever or
mathematica whatever suppose we do know
how to find out the value of this
integral
okay but you see here this k
this k is involving the alpha
and let us not forget that we don't know
alpha what do we know here
you see the left hand side of this
equation the length
that is very much known to us the
young's modulus is known to us
we know the second moment of area and
suppose
we are actually given a certain value of
the applied load
so this p is also known to us so in this
entire equation
in the left hand side and the right hand
side considering them together
the only thing that we don't really know
is this
k but we do know
or we we have means of solving this
integration
for different different values of k so
we now have uh an equation
a complete complicated equation for
which we have to put in some effort
but we do have the means to find out the
value of
k given a certain value of p
okay now why is that good news
it is good news because uh
the moment we have a value of k
which satisfies this equation we can
immediately say that we know the value
of that unknown alpha which has been
bugging us
from uh from from the very beginning
okay
so we have we have accepted and
acknowledged our ignorance about our
alpha
but we have not gotten rid of it okay
because it is very much
present within this scale so what we can
do now
is that we can say that
given a value of
a p
we can find
a value of
a a value of k
let's say that this equation is
such that
this equation numbered hash is satisfied
and the moment we have such a thing
we can say that we can find so basically
we can find
the value of alpha
because
a is equal to sine alpha by 2.
all right then what about the question
uh about uh finding the
critical value of p okay
so uh let's let's add
and just carry on this uh video a little
bit longer and
uh take a look uh at what can do after
we have
uh after i have found out this value of
uh
okay okay so
or or or if if you can do a little bit
of a simplification
so let's go to the next slide and
write this thing again okay so l
is equal to twice square root of e i by
p integration 0 to pi by 2
d phi
1 minus k square
sine square phi under the square root
now uh we can
you can write this as
p l square
by e i
i just taken this term here and this
terms also here
in this fashion
and then
we write it in this way
of y square e i
by l square the motivation of
suddenly bringing about this term here
in the denominator
okay through the introduction of this pi
square is that we
we know uh that this particular thing is
nothing but the
euler buckling load this pi square e i
by l square this is the euler buckling
load
okay so uh you see that because i have
introduced this
uh basically the 1 by square root of pi
square here
i will have to compensate by writing
this pi on the right hand side also
but the good thing about about about the
situation
is that we have now
in our hand
an estimate of this p
in terms of the ratio with the euler
buckling row
load so this is p by
a p euler
okay because that is what this
particular combination is
uh so uh
so suppose you you rethink about this
problem
in the sense that you know the
value of this ratio p by p euler
then which is equivalent to saying that
you know the value of p
then you can find the value of k
to find the value of alpha
and once we know the value of alpha
we will we are going to show how we can
proceed
towards finding the deflected shape of
the beam
all right so now that is the second part
of the
of the solution uh which we are going to
look into uh in in the next video so
already this video is quite has become
quite long so i'll end it
here and continue uh from here in the
next
video thank you very much